はい届出26歳最後の一日でございまーさーじむ社長です
と言うとめちゃわざわざ来てくれたなんで
ありがとうなほんまあの分かってユーチューバーと言われたはじめするとか今や
27歳当たるとシャッター問題じゃないと思うんですね年齢者経歴の問題視して来ない
力む長いし以上のマラサダ子増設でも
とミックさん東レの違いは結婚してるかしてないか
浮かんばいけないよあれ混ぜてという山ニッチの日なんて許さ分後17分ほどですね
さすがに26歳の最後は腹筋で締めさせていただきましたお願いします
[音楽]
計19
シャア
いやー
は仕上げ100かいはできるならまあこれが
26らいだーシーン
[音楽]
しています
知った
持っています
ん
オンゲー
そんな顔はねぇ
あと4プルーフ
ではプロ前に買いに行ってきます
まあ今やますもう脈わーと cocco
一夫一婦んっはい買えないとこい
言われた
なっちゃったねあ
[音楽]
ブーバー即興
です
うんも陣地をいなべ者様してる床がありげ
ああああああ
ううううううっうぅうう
いろんな山14feb no
40そう ani
おっん
uh
tuhan
いやぁああああああ
滑っいる
めちゃん
んでないなぁ
[音楽]
山村猛省中 s ジャッチ月目指すでしょ
なびてぃめぇっレッドボーダー通常召喚
終わったおめでとうございます
10バズズデウスばてる ds 3 b シアター
設置しちゃっただ今の時刻はデーン2:41もうすぐ3で迎えますが
いう業の年収を
しています
[音楽]
14dec の夜8時でございます
愛知日が終わりかけておりますホント皆さんツイッターとかいろんなところでお祝いの
メッセージ本当にありがとうございます
とりあえずの誕生日なった日は盛大に祝っていただいて夜中後輩と出かけたり
なぁと体に行こうとしたんですけれどもよくよく考えたらお酒飲んで食べないなと思っ
て中まで入ったけどサウンドに入らずに帰ったり朝早く起きてから畑の動画を撮ってで
もうすぐ君
ですねーまくらぶかちゃんバカみたいにをかねっ投げ負けて回したりあ
朝までてるでよろしくお願いますまあそんで今に至るっていう誕生日で知った ig
30 a 27歳の誕生日でした
もうあの昔からずっと観てくださる方ならわかると思うんですけども
ユーチューバーん量外においてなんか肇社長ってわかって大学生ユーチューバー
みたいなのかすごいイメージ的に大きいと思うんですよ分かってユーチューバーなら
すごい勢いの
あればかものがアホにも合ってるみたいなそんな彼がもう27歳ですよやばいよ
もう youtube やり始めてもうすぐ8年目とかになるんで比較的な27日た
若い子の顔だと思うんですけども
実は立派なアナさんになっております
デジモン自己分析して僕に足りないものってたくさんあると思うんですよ
常識じゃないんじゃね社会に出てなくて味
ロース気がなかったりたまに周りが見えなくてやらかすこととまあよくあるんですけど
も合わせるものねいろいろ本当欠点だらけの人間だなって思いますただそんな僕に唯一
できるのはまぁ失敗を認めて謝ることとかその反省を生かして次に生かすとかまぁあと
本当に心から動画を撮るのが好きだとか
そこだけだなと最近思いましたずっと一人で中やってきたんですけど最近だとこんな
いろんな人に過去
あえて動画をやらせていただいておりますが今後はニーズ7歳としてあのね子供で言い
たいんですよ
メンタルは愛も
なんかいい年してとか言われると思うんですけども子供じゃなくなったら
ユーチューバーも終わりだなと思ってるんですちゃ空今後も動画を頑張っていきたいと
おもいます
素敵なお誕生日ありがとうございました
[音楽]
いいたいとこだったんですけどもえっ
はぁ
家にですね配達日指定で知らない人からお届き物も届いたんですよ
マジで怖いですちょっと見ます普通ちょっとヤバいんですよね
住所とか言ってっ住所とか言ってたまあ見せないんですけども名前が貞子って書いて
あるんですよ
嘘だいや普通にヤバイっすよ
アップ商品名が14feb の商品名バースデープレゼントとかになります
プレゼントいやだありがとうございますないよ僕でプレゼントを送ってくださるかと
いるんですけどもあの web という事務所に降りましてちょっと事務所に届けて
ください
なんか僕の来ない家住所めっちゃ粒子してバレてるんですけどもいるんですよなか一定
数へお手紙とかプレゼントとか直接この絵に届ける方絶対やめていたら
けれどすごい助かりますそれを許すちゃう等も遠因に届いていなんか迷惑なんで手紙を
着てもプレゼント起きても一切観ませんしそのままさせていただきます申し訳ないです
プレゼントとかある際は是非ずる所の方へよろしくお願いしますってなんか
誕生日に貞子からのプレゼントですとりあえず開けてみます
強いようだ矢部臓器とかた忽那っぽいですよねえめっちゃ猫らーが何かた事って本当に
あるんで俺
いきます
ど2分
本当に寒って名前の方でしたにため
[拍手]
[音楽]
これこれこういったになんねー
何
えっ
カエルだえ
めっちゃ座でなになになになにえっとぉとぉ人が入ってそれ故イ
あめちゃくちゃ字がきれい弾みシャツお酒前田肇さんえって書いてありますハピ
バースデーお湯ダンパーです
有担保なので自分で作ったのかとありがとうございます
いやダメなんですよ直接送っちゃダメなんですよもう
レンジで2分にチェーンして使ってください目の上に乗せて使ったり肩に当てたりして
ください中に入っているのは好きなので安心です
体にはくれぐれも気をつけてね和美さん大好き
ありがとうございます
ただ直接送るのはダメ子はめちゃくちゃ俺の杖やっぱ
誰です作りポスターなり難いですけど家に直接送るだけ本気にやめてくださいだけで
27歳も電気に元気にがんばるぞ
明日の名古屋
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ